hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast and
i'm just checking in on you
why are you checking in on me bill is it
because you care
or are you just pretending to care
so i'll listen
and then i'll go out and buy a [ __ ]
comfortable mattress
that advertises on your podcast hey you
got me
no you know what i do i do i care on a
human to human level
you know i never really made up my mind
how i feel about humans
in general
let me pontificate on that [ __ ] idea
i'll tell you this as far as human to
humans i don't i don't understand why
juwan howard
got anything
other than a chuckle from the [ __ ]
sports media
i just do not understand
when i was growing up you could do that
and it was not even a suspension
i i don't even
hey just ain't saying james jawad howard
just threw a punch he didn't he [ __ ]
threw a half-assed slap
in a crowd
and some kid in the prime of his life
who plays a non-contact sport got hit in
the head he's gonna be fine everybody's
fine they got a little heated
and like usual the little fella there
running his [ __ ] yap
who called the [ __ ] timeout didn't
substitute or anything just to be a big
ten [ __ ]
all right
just to be a [ __ ]
was about to get the slap that he needed
i'm telling you in that moment you see
why the world is so disrespectful and
everyone would say yes a grown man
resorting to violence
how could he resort to violence as they
sit there and they talk about us doing
[ __ ] to russia who are going to do some
[ __ ] to ukrainians but that's all fine
because that's war
i mean you can drop bombs and blow up
babies and [ __ ] trying to get the
[ __ ] evil bearded guy you're going
after but you know if you kill some
babies along the way that's fine but if
jawan howard tries to slap some snarky
little [ __ ] in the head who [ __ ]
deserved it
all right
juwan was [ __ ] heated he tried to
walk away
all right but then he's got to do the
handshake line and it was just like i'm
not shaking your hand because you're
acting like a [ __ ]
and you do not deserve my respect as a
man that's all he was trying to do so
what does the little housewife do on
wisconsin he starts running his [ __ ]
yap yelling at a guy who's like what 6
11.
yelling at a guy 6 11 like he would ever
do this in a bar
all right
then what happens the little the little
fella gets the big fella mad the big
fella starts swinging
some innocent guy on the other side
takes a [ __ ] slap to their head
okay
that's what he gets
for [ __ ] getting involved
i've been in enough bars to know to mind
your own business
and juwan calls off and he gets a half a
slap
if juwan really wanted the [ __ ] slaps
he would have knocked down a whole row
of college students that's what he would
have done it was a half a [ __ ] slap
for the half a [ __ ] douche who was
running his yap like he could kick
juan's ass and i i really think
that you know
if there wasn't so many places
to distract people
like podcasts i'm part of the problem
they got to sensationalize everything
i mean that's that's
that's not that should be settled
between the two of them the next time
they [ __ ] play one another they call
each other up or whatever the [ __ ]
somebody buy somebody a beer and that's
it you know
this just did a controversy at the end
of the wolverines badgers game
that's it meanwhile tensions rising
tensions rising over the ukraine hundred
thousand troops over russia
that's all fine
that's all [ __ ] fine you know what
we're gonna come walking over there like
that kid who got smacked by [ __ ]
juwan and we're gonna go over there i
mean how many times you know
you know enough with the the away games
here
and if elected
i don't know why we just don't you know
just pull it all back
just pull it all back
you know
turn all the bases into day care centers
let these people who want to take over
the world try and take over the world
what are they going to do to us
what are they going to do we got all the
grain we need
we got waffle houses we have nuclear
weapons
right fire up the steel mills again
in pittsburgh knock down the walls not
the walls the malls in pittsburgh
you just get it going again
i liked where we were
you know between world war one and world
war ii where everybody's just like why
don't we just [ __ ] mind our own
business over here
you know
a couple of drunks rolling around on the
floor what the [ __ ] are you gonna get in
the middle of that for
you know why we're going over there
because they got some [ __ ] in the ground
that you can turn into a battery to
stick at the bottom of a tesla
and then they pretend that they care
about the people
oh jesus bill
get off your [ __ ]
your [ __ ] liberal stump here
i'm kind of all over the map
you know
cause i'm being like hey man like why is
war legal man
what about the people man and at the
same time i don't have a problem with
the 611 man slapping the [ __ ] out of a
guy who's probably taller than me
but doesn't look it next to a 611 guy he
should have you know
they should have cleared out and they
should have a slap fight right at center
court
you know
that should be the coach's option
and what should happen is
you know
the team's going in into the [ __ ]
locker room
the stadium empties out and when the
game's over
the two coaches come back out and if
they're still mad enough
in the empty arena with nobody watching
nothing recorded no video
they just settle it
they just slap the [ __ ] out of each
other until they get it out of their
system they go alright that's fine
they leave hey by the way i just tweeted
this i just found a [ __ ] gem you know
as i mentioned the great clark gilly's
pass so i've been uh you know
watching all of his videos and stuff
truly one of the one of the toughest
guys
who ever played the game
and just an incredible teammate and all
that part of all of those great
islander teams that won four in a row so
you know there's a fight that he had
one of his uh famous ones
um
where he goes at it i forget what team
the guy played for or was playing for at
the time
but um
what was it eddie eddie uh hospital
boxcar hospital right so
that guy's kind of famous
because when he fought clark gillies
clark caught him with like a straight
left or a straight right and then
when eddie ducked his head down it
like gillies timed the uppercut
perfectly and he just dropped
i mean it would have dropped anybody but
of course you know hockey fans
so many of them never had a fight in
their life gotta be like oh [ __ ] guy
good you know whatever anyway so i'm
going like boxcar hospital now there's
no [ __ ] way
this guy got a nickname like this
and all he ever did was lose to clark
gilly so i started watching this guy's
fights no [ __ ] joke this dude
living up to the name and a lo and
behold
november 27 1987
one of my new favorite enforcers of all
time
eddie boxcar hospital [ __ ] drops off
samuelson
hospital is playing for the sabers and
uh samuelson was playing for um
the whalers and i think the announcers
were saying that
ulf was sort of the new young enforcer
on the whalers and
took eddie's job
so eddie was like all right and they see
stayed in the adams division
and uh went out there and i got the best
of their new younger i guess what they
thought was going to be more improved
enforcer and as a bruins fan it's always
great to see elf
get the [ __ ] kicked out of him and it
was nice to actually see him drop the
gloves
[Laughter]
as opposed to turtling
yes i will never get over that all right
anyway
so there you go just like that just like
that running my yap no facts
no facts just momentum
celebrating
uh oh my god i've been podcasting for 15
years this
is that right holy [ __ ] 15 years in june
i'll have been podcasting
and i have 30 years in stand up
on march 2nd
and i got to tell you man i'm i'm
nearing the end here
[Laughter]
not of my life
but i swear to god man
there's a level of busy that you get
where you're just like uh you know i
think i just want to go to a soda
fountain with a bunch of old people
and read a newspaper and have a [ __ ]
root beer float i think i think that
that's what i thought i wanted
an infinity pool i don't think i want
that anymore
i think i want an afternoon off
a local newspaper
just read about scuttlebutt
i don't want to i don't you know you
know what i think that that's the way to
go i don't want to hear i don't want to
[ __ ] hear
about all this international
[ __ ] horrible [ __ ] that corporations
are doing
you know and power and and natural
resources and the [ __ ] ocean and all
that you know what i need at this point
i want scuttlebutt
i want to know what the the [ __ ]
ethel's there's no ethels left
you know what's funny baby boomer names
i i'd better like
to young people are like that you know
when i was a kid like hazel ethel
blanche
those are all people names old
lady
names
now
let's see
wild fashion
names are popular
oh because that's what what else would
hipsters be doing but [ __ ] living a
century ago
old i should talk cuz i love [ __ ]
dive bars and [ __ ]
defunct sports franchises old ladies
names
um 100 sweet old ladies names rooted in
tradition now
30 chic vintage old lady names no
all right i got a
baby boom a popular baby boomer girl
names is what i got to check baby
boomer
girl names
popular all right let's see what they
were
judy
carolyn
margaret janet
these are all gonna be old ladies now
like when the young comics
make fun of an old lady where i used to
be like okay uh you know easy there
ebenezer
you know
hurry all right there gladys right
they're gonna be sitting there going
okay okay
okay janet
okay okay i think it's bedtime susan
um
more items let's see here
the chicago tribune all of these [ __ ]
newspapers it's like when are they gonna
learn nobody's gonna [ __ ] subscribe
to you online it's over
okay the readers make the news now
we just make [ __ ] up
that's it and people you know what
i guess podcast this is all [ __ ]
scuttlebutt right
top names of the 1960s
all right this is when i was born
let's see what we got here there's me a
lot of bobs
bills mikes here we go mike michael was
number one
number one name for a lady was lisa
david john james robert there's bobby
mark william billy
richard
thomas jeffrey stephen joseph timothy
kevin scott brian charles
paul daniel i had all friends name that
i knew like five michaels about five
davids a bunch of john's
a couple of james you go by james you go
by jimmy
a bunch of bobs bunch of mocks
richards dickey
tom's bunch of toms
not a lot of jeffs there were some jeffs
not a lot of jeff's a lot of stevens
joseph
could be joey timmy's kevin's and then
let's see here lisa mary susan karen
that that name's going to go away
kimberly patricia a lot of patricia's
linda's
donna michelle cynthia deborah a lot of
deborah's debras were always fun
deborahs were fun susans were fun
um
sharon
nancy
let's go back a few years before that
popular baby names for the 1940s this is
when it's going to start getting a
little weird
let's see oh these aren't bad
carol sandra sharon judith susan
classic named michael
was there michael in the uh
in the bible
and jesus said to mikey dude
you want to split a steak and cheese
baby boomers names getting old
gender-bending names are in
yeah
i don't know i could have told you that
a long time ago all these [ __ ] kids
you meet nowadays i'm so bad at like
remembering names but now like every kid
like
like you'll meet someone not every kid
but there's a lot of kids you meet him
it's just like i've never met
whatever name you just said that i now
forget
i'm never gonna [ __ ] remember
that um
i've been at that age for a long time
now
where you
as you introduce me i've already forgot
what your name started with
even if it's a three-syllable name
my name is jessica by the time you get
to kah i've already forgot what the
beginning of it was
car was that car
cara karen
charithy
um all right so billy no sticks billy no
sticks all right you guys guilted me you
[ __ ] guilted me so i've been off the
sticks for [ __ ] 10 days cutting it
down not quitting cutting it down and i
will i will continue to talk about it
okay
these [ __ ] [ __ ] in a.a they go
down there they've been sober like 20
years they're still talking about it
i can tell you this
sobriety
is boring as [ __ ]
it's not boring as [ __ ] it's just i
think i'm too childish for it
it takes a [ __ ] adult it really does
to be sober you really have to be a
goddamn adult
like i had i had a long i had a long
[ __ ] day i had a long [ __ ] date
listen i don't dig ditches
okay i don't plumb sinks
i don't i don't stand out in the middle
of the street with my back to traffic
looking into a [ __ ] tripod
surveying
i don't go down in those [ __ ]
manholes i don't roof i don't do any of
that [ __ ]
you know i do all day i think
just have to [ __ ] think and solve
so i can figure out how i can get this
person
to have the pie hit them in the face
and it's gonna it's gonna read
and you know
i'm not billy bigbrain okay i got a
[ __ ] midsize brain up there and yeah
you know you get a little tired
and what happens is
people keep talking and all i just start
thinking of like
wouldn't it be great to just tap out
right
now you know take something
drink something
smoke something
that would just take me
to a mindset far far away wouldn't that
be fantastic
that
that is the solution
um
what kind of a sadistic god is is there
that we can't just all go around and
just get [ __ ] up and have a good time
that it makes you be a fat [ __ ] and die
younger
you know what i mean
just sit around eating [ __ ] mushy
peas and [ __ ]
and couscous
you live to end your 90s
you know what that reminded me one time
i remember hearing this [ __ ] guy
he was drinking a giant one of those
giant [ __ ] cheap ass jugs of wine
every day
his health was bad had [ __ ] diabetes
and all of that [ __ ]
his friends would always come by and be
like you know you got to stop you got up
but blah blah blah you got to [ __ ] it
you know
you got so much to live for and the guy
was just like listen i'm good i'm
enjoying myself
you know
just this is how i want to go out
let's see here
i'm not going to say who the athlete's
name is
oh boy last i heard he was on up
no
last i heard
this athlete was just hanging out on his
front porch he lived down south
you know
and he was living that charlie daniels
song
he just leave this long-haired country
boy alone you know
i get drunk in the morning i get stoned
in the morning get drunk in the
afternoon like he was just doing that
which sounded
if you could just get past all the
people you hurt by doing that
that sounded [ __ ] awesome
so last i heard he was just gonna sort
of drink and smoke himself to death on
his front porch and just wanted to be
left alone
and now i'm doing an update now he lives
in an
assisted living facility
he mainly gets around via wheelchair
or a walker
when he fills up to it those days are
rare
uh
i don't know
they should have like two different
kinds of assisted living
facilities you know those are people who
want to keep living
and those who just want to have a good
time
you know
and you come in there's like a humidor
bill who's kidding who you're designing
your own
assisted living facility all right let's
do this on the podcast this is
[Music]
this is what my dream assisted
living facility am i creating a reality
show right now
they're always going up to people in
their 20s and fixing up their cars and
[ __ ] and giving them [ __ ] you know
tummy tucks or whatever the [ __ ] they do
for young people what about old people
they should go in
and you should get that who was that guy
from that 70s ashton kutcher should
[ __ ]
no he did he did punk'd
who's the guy who did uh uh pimp my ride
ah [ __ ] what was his name the rapper
he's i used to love that guy he would
just [ __ ] laugh at your car
what the [ __ ] was his name that old pimp
my i watch like every episode pimp my
ride
host
exhibit
they should get exhibit
just hear me honest get him to do
like a pimp my my assisted living
facility
and he comes in and he just he laughs at
your your [ __ ]
tub
that has a door on it
you can make fun of that you hollered
out a ups truck to turn it into your
[ __ ] tub shower
uh you know
i've never seen a jacuzzi with a [ __ ]
chair in it
um [ __ ] like that right he could [ __ ]
crack on all the old people
and then he comes in and he just [ __ ]
puts a bar in
gets him a nice big flat screen tv dude
i gotta tell you something the way that
we're we're handling old people
and veterans
you know while you're in active military
they'll let you run out on the [ __ ]
football field in an nfl game carrying
the flag and then the second you don't
re-up they don't give a [ __ ] if you live
under a bridge um that's depressing
you know what
if i was
okay so my my
dream
assistive facility
all right
i had to have a humidor
all right i'd have a soda fountain
i do all that old people [ __ ]
i'd eat like grilled cheese sandwiches
and tuna milk i don't like a tuna melt
it always makes me sick to my stomach
uh
we'll go grilled cheese sandwiches
you know uh
[Music]
it's a [ __ ] old person salad
whatever it is it's like italian
dressing on it so it's not even healthy
we have what i got humidor i got root
beer floats what the [ __ ] else do i need
and just like a tv
in a bed
and all the sports packages
that's it little refrigerator
got some beers in there
right
and then every once in a while
they come by
you know when i want to go to bed at
night they just come by with a couple of
edibles
this is an assisted first i mean this is
to me like if this was what heaven was
and the heaven was be you you didn't
have to pay for any of that you know
you still considered a good father a
good husband
he didn't get fat can you imagine that i
mean that's [ __ ] heaven right there
you could just [ __ ]
eat ice cream and grilled cheese
sandwiches
smoke a cigar have some bourbon and then
somebody comes by with whatever your
drug of choices and that little white
cup like they the paper cup like they
had and [ __ ] one flew over the
cuckoo's nest
and you take it you feel great and you
don't you don't hurt anybody
it would be [ __ ] phenomenal
um
but you can't do that you gotta eat kale
salad
and drink plenty of water
i'll tell you what my drug is eight
hours sleep that's what i say now
you give me eight hours sleep oh i'm
ready to take on the [ __ ] world
um
all right let me uh let me do the
podcast i know this is what happens when
i get too [ __ ] busy i i literally i
don't know what it is i think about
retiring and drinking myself to death
i don't know i'm not gonna do it but i
don't know why that's what my my that's
why i have to watch out because that's
how my brain [ __ ] works
i go to the end
all right i can't just perform
at you know in one state i have to go to
all 50. then i have to go to canada i
can't just go to canada i have to go out
of the province i got to go to all the
[ __ ] continents ah
lunatic [ __ ] lunatic
um all right grove cleaning everybody
did you know that only nine percent of
plastic actually gets recycled no matter
how much we put in our recycling bin
yeah
that's what i've heard i don't know is
nine percent at grove collaborative they
believe it's time to ditch single-use
plastic
for good
grove carries hundreds of products aimed
at replacing single-use plastics across
your home and personal care routine
finally i love that companies like this
are getting started by young people who
are going to have to live in the [ __ ]
world that [ __ ] like me who've been
drinking bottled water for the last 30
[ __ ] years have left them
and by 2025 grove will be a hundred
percent plastic free
uh like groves
companies concentrated
cleaners and refillable glass bottles
they're friendlier to the planet and
twice as affected as the leading natural
brands
switch to sustainable products for every
room in your home from laundry care to
hand soaps and more
grove co does that mean company
um has you covered with safe formulas
and refillable packaging that never
compromises on performance just over two
million households already shopping
sustainably at grove i'm going to do
this i already did it with the liquid
death
just sort of wean the plastic
plastic out i i want like in like three
you know whatever by 2050
hipsters to be into plastic because they
don't make it anymore
uh and of course there's all these
negative people yeah
you cut down trees again
no
just let mother nature do her job she's
she's about ready to spill or drink on
us the ocean is rising
um
go to grove.com
and i'll i'll tell you guys from beyond
the grave that i called it because i'm
living right near the ocean
today to get a free gift set worth up to
50 dollars with your first order plus
shipping is fast and free get started
right now at grove.comgrove.comburr
grove.com
there you go after all my craziness that
i was talking about that was actually
something uplifting is there anything
you know underrated
people creating companies that are at
least making a [ __ ] effort
to try to turn this ship around for all
the young people you know
[ __ ] amazing
you know we could have learned a thing
or two from the people that were living
here first
they had the right idea
you know what i mean
i mean think about it you probably
didn't live as long
okay if you lived like native americans
indians whatever you're supposed to say
maybe you didn't live as long maybe you
only lived into your 50s but look at
this
you [ __ ]
you got your own horse right right right
off the bat it's cool
okay there's no no gmos in your food
nobody really telling you when to get up
and as long as you scored on a on a big
hunt the day before you could [ __ ]
chill for the week every time you
[ __ ] killed something huge and
everybody got to eat you could like
chill for a week i remember reading that
that there was a lot of down time as a
caveman
you know way more than we have now
i don't think cavemen would like rise
and grind
well maybe not cavemen were rise and
don't get eaten but uh
how much
leisure time
before modern
society
leisure time in ma no no no
how much leisure time do the happiest
people have
let's see here
let's just go to
this i'm too lazy to figure out what i
really wanted to get the answer to
too little
and people tend to get stressed yeah
that's probably why you think about hey
what if i just sold everything and
moved to wyoming
uh too much and people tend to to feel
idle okay too little people tend to get
stressed too much and
people tend to feel idle well that's
another thing too right
sitting around too much i sit at me
during the pandemic all of a sudden
you're like bill
why don't you go get some ice cream
sandwiches
um
i'm not reading all of this [ __ ] all
right i'm gonna close on this before uh
before uh before i wrap it up here we
get to listen to a bonus episode
of the thursday afternoon just before
friday monday morning podcast um
i gotta say condolences rest in peace to
one of my favorite comics when i was
coming up and i always watched him he
was on tv he was absolutely hilarious
the amazing jonathan
passed away at just 63 years of age and
um
one of the just most unique
stand-up comedians i've ever seen he was
the guy like
before he came along like magic was
corny
and he brought like this [ __ ] rock
star vibe to it he made fun of magic
while he did cool magic
tricks um called himself the freddy
krueger of comedy
and um
you know a buddy of mine steve byrne
made this wonderful documentary about
him
and uh he was actually the guy that let
me know that he passed uh this morning
and he was also the guy that was nice
enough
to uh set me up on a little zoom call to
call him just a few days ago and i had
never met the guy
and steve found out you know steve knew
i was a fan of his and he found out that
he liked some of my stuff too and uh
i got on the uh you know
got to do a facetime call with him and i
and the whole time i was like i can't
believe i'm talking to the amazing
jonathan
like this is the [ __ ] guy like i used
to be like you know back in the the
stand-up 80s the boom
when any time there was a comedy on the
road or an evening at the improv
like
he did all of those shows and i remember
being so [ __ ] excited
when he was gonna be on and he always
killed always made me laugh the next day
at school all my friends that were into
comedy or when i was working in the
warehouse were all quoting his jokes
um
i got to talk to him and he was you know
making me laugh and he was that close to
the end and that's just you know
seemed like the kind of guy he was so
thank you to steve byrne for
giving me that moment with one of my
idols
and um
yeah i wish i wish i got to work with
him i i wish i got to know him more and
all that our paths just didn't cross but
i always always was a huge fan of his
and um i can tell you this on that zoom
call he had me die and laughing he was
just [ __ ]
hilarious he was like you know mocking
his own death just joking about
joking around that he was towards the
end man just really
a hilarious hilarious dude so um rest in
peace to him please go on um
you know go on youtube
check him out if you're into comedy you
should know about the guy uh
let me see what was the name of the
amazing jonathan
documentary that's steve byrne one of
the most big-hearted guys
in the business always amazing
came out in 2018
look at that three and a half out of
four stars right yep
is that right
my [ __ ] eyes are going here yeah
three and a half out of four stars it's
a [ __ ] great documentary um
you should definitely know about the guy
so rest in peace and thank you for all
the laughs and thanks for inspiring me
to become a comedian the amazing
jonathan rest in peace all right that is
the podcast everybody
um
yeah listen to the music picked out by
andrew females then we have a bonus
half hour episode of the thursday
afternoon just before friday monday
morning podcast have a great weekend
your cons
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday february 24th
how the hell are you how's it going oh
really
well that's good
i'm back in los angeles
saw my wife saw my dog i'm in a great
mood
um another trip
another trip across the country you know
when i land and i get off the plane and
what do i see i'm getting a bunch of
[ __ ] from all the canada [ __ ]
up north
i gotta ask you why the [ __ ] does this
always happen to me as a sports fan
anytime i suffer a tragic loss as a
sports fan if i'm not already in the
area of the victorious fans i'm going
there the following week you guys long
time listeners of this podcast might
remember
back when the jets were good
you know
when they spent all that money that one
year when they lifted the salary cap and
they [ __ ] loaded up and they were
making their run
you know when they beat us the first
time then all the jets fans were talking
[ __ ]
and then they came up to foxborough for
game two and got absolutely ass raped
on national television absolutely
[ __ ] ass raped so the playoff game
comes playoffs playoff game comes around
who knows which way it's going to go
division rivalry you never know
sometimes they go every other sometimes
somebody wins two three in a row then
the other team wins three row who the
[ __ ] knows right
either way where the [ __ ] am i when that
game happens i'm in atlantic city new
jersey
on jim norton's um anti-social uh
network tour
right so now i'm sitting there and i'm
so focused on the game i'm not even
thinking i'm just thinking jesus christ
i'm in [ __ ] new jersey they gotta win
if they don't win i'm gonna be getting
[ __ ] before i even hit the mic of course
they lose brady throws arguably the
worst pass of his career that screen
pass
where he just went way
i don't know what the [ __ ] it was lobbed
it up and got away from him and that way
we never recovered and they also benched
wes welker for making fun of rex ryan
you know because he had a foot fetish
you know it's just unbelievable so
whatever jeez i'm going through the pain
of that loss again and where the [ __ ] am
i i'm in atlantic god damn city new
jersey right so now what
okay we got olympic hockey coming up i'm
one of the few people in this country
that gives a [ __ ]
you know one of the few [ __ ] people
that gives a [ __ ] we seem to be winning
pretty handily five to one whatever
canada is struggling
right [ __ ] you you were struggling
because now you're strutting around with
your sir repaired [ __ ] chest
you barely beat estonia
that was a [ __ ] nail biter to the end
you [ __ ] play us
it was one to nothing i mean yeah i
gotta be honest with you it didn't feel
like one or nothing it felt like five to
nothing
we completely out coached we didn't we
didn't do one [ __ ] thing to adjust to
your forecheck we didn't do a [ __ ]
thing
ah that was frustrating you had one
[ __ ] ping-pong goal
all right so what are these what are
these canadian [ __ ] doing now
oh and in the meanwhile and somewhere in
that though the women had the game one
and all they had to do was just hit a
hit uh an empty netter they hit the post
it was laying right on the [ __ ]
goal line they scoop it up tied up and
then canada i'm letting the americans
know because most of them still don't
know this
um
or the people down here in the united
states i should say because we're all
americans by the way
for all you dumb [ __ ] up in canada you
[ __ ] americans you're an american too
you live in the americas there's north
america and south america we're all from
the americas
all right
you are american
the same way somebody in poland and
somebody in ireland they're both
european
okay for some reason they're calling us
americans but at the end of the [ __ ]
day if i want to pull [ __ ] hairs you
guys are also americans
anyways so i get off the [ __ ] plane
and i got like 20 30 [ __ ] texts from
these canadian [ __ ] going oh i can't
wait to hear your take on the [ __ ]
hockey right because they're you know
they're actually hoping
that down here this country is like
devastated and i hate to tell you this
canadian people
i would venture to guess that eighty
percent of people they don't even know
as you notice when we lost
both games to you guys nothing was set
ablaze down here
like you guys do up there nobody even
i'll tell you this is how
little popularity hockey has
in how little they're known it's weird
it's like totally niche and all the
arenas sell out
but
once you get beyond that like nobody
knows who anybody is
um teemu salani was on my flight
evidently
um
because when i got off i'm standing at
baggage claim as i'm reading all these
tweets
you know from these canadian people just
mind scrolling them on my phone for some
reason
um
i look up and teemu salami comes walking
by and i nodded to him you know when you
see somebody that iconic and i'm
thinking in my head
i thought it was uh pavel bury
that's how [ __ ] old i am i'm like a
skinny cocky guy with a page boy haircut
valbury
and then i was like no it's not him team
usalani and he'd already gone by
and this is nobody knew who the [ __ ] he
was the guy was literally he's coming
back from the [ __ ] olympics
and and his
shirt says
nhlpa
nhl players associations for the ladies
right
he's wearing
and i'm in the nhl shirt still nobody
recognizes him he goes over to the side
he's getting his own [ __ ] bags
because he's a hockey player right
here's what priority he's sitting first
class he's got that kind of money one of
the first bags down is his a giant
hockey bag
with the anaheim ducks logo on it and
still
nobody noticed people looked at the bag
and they were kind of like oh that's odd
that's a big bag
they were kind of like well you know
what they got scaffolding in there
somebody doing some payton
nobody had any [ __ ] idea and he takes
it off himself
first ballot hall of fame hockey players
standing right there so i'm sorry
canadians as much as you want to revel
in this as you called it your domination
i guess you dominated because you won
both goals but you certainly did not
dominate the games
with your one-nothing [ __ ] [ __ ]
victories they weren't [ __ ] they
were good victories
um you know what it is i only got tweets
from 20 people why am i taking down the
whole [ __ ] country you know what good
for you canada you know it's your sport
and it isn't even the joy of winning i
think up there i think it's the relief
of not losing because i just had a buddy
of mine
from up there you know he knows i'm
coming up there she goes you know bring
your skates
uh bring some gloves we'll supply they
said they'll supply the rest of the
stuff and it's like dude i'm not using
somebody else's hockey stuff okay it's
[ __ ] gross
i'll take my bruises
all right um
but anyways he left a message he goes
yeah he goes hey you know sorry about
you guys losing uh he goes we want it
and then he paused and he goes thank god
so that's the way it is up there um
and i got to tell you nothing down here
is like that not even like i'd say the
closest thing
would be men's olympic basketball but
even then if they lose we don't light
[ __ ] on fire
we just go out a bunch of [ __ ]
spoiled brats they're making too much
money they don't want to listen to the
coaches yeah yeah that's all we do we
don't give a [ __ ]
we don't send people to siberia
you know they don't get killed like they
do down in colombia if they don't
[ __ ] you know
inbound the soccer ball correctly
whatever the [ __ ] you do out there in
the pitch
um yeah people just don't give a [ __ ] to
that level
put it this way i actually typed in i
was trying to type in olympic hockey and
i and i wrote stanley cup
that's what i give a [ __ ] about as i
mean obviously i want to win the gold
you know what [ __ ] me over was the first
gold that i saw was the 1980 team
and
it was our amateur team
beating the russians it was the cold war
it's just never going to be as good as
that again now it's just like
it's like a couple of all-star teams
playing you know what i mean i don't
know
that sucks that we we
got along with russia for a while it
really killed the rivalry
you know
back in the day those team canada games
and the usa teams and then the russians
when they couldn't even get into the
[ __ ] league unless they did some
moscow and the hudson [ __ ] and these
[ __ ] guys would come over he had no
idea who they were
they come over and start kicking the
[ __ ] out of us at least the americans
and then the flyers had to basically
cheat and take a couple of two-handers
to their ankles
and called it hockey
i love how the flyers organization tells
that story
when they when they actually beat the
russians
yeah it was a great they played some
great hockey where they turned their
sticks into clubs and they just
basically beat them they just beat him
up
which is funny
[ __ ] hilarious
but uh
is it i don't think it's hockey and you
know what the league suffered forever
forever in that but anyways
congratulations
to the canadians uh for not losing
um the gold medal game congratulations
okay your cities are safe your starbucks
windows
will be intact and um i can take comfort
in the fact knowing that the stanley cup
has been in the good old u.s of a since
1994. oh you like that why don't you sit
on that trophy
all right there new brunswick i'm
[ __ ] coming
all right nova scotia next week it's
coming mockton halifax
sometime that begins with an h
hamilton toronto london ottawa montreal
winnipeg
calgary
vancouver some [ __ ] island out there
back to calgary
a couple times back to ottawa it's gonna
be crazy
um and i know i'm gonna drink like a
fish and smoke cigars and i'm gonna look
like i'm 400 years older and i i'm going
to accept that
um i can't wait to get up there i can't
wait to skate on that [ __ ] canal like
a [ __ ] twinkle toes there
um and then i got some pond hockey
possibly lined up
it's going to be [ __ ]
insane that's how i'm going to keep the
booze weight down
i'm going to drink it up at night and
then i'm going to shake it off for
morning practice and then i'm going to
stumble into the theater
right like a grizzled vet and i'm going
to [ __ ] knock out my hour in 15
minutes of uh
of stuff all right that's what i got
going on so anyways i know i broke your
balls but that was me actually saying
congratulations
to canada what a relief you won
nothing got damaged
your sons are [ __ ] [ __ ] crosby you
knew he was going to score on that
goddamn breakaway i knew it i knew he
was and i actually tweeted the guy never
chokes and people like um last year
against the bruins i don't think he
showed up
the whole team got shut down
all right and if you go through any
great athlete's career there's gonna be
moments
you know
there's moments but generally speaking
as much as you don't like the guy can
you give it up for what a [ __ ]
unbelievable player is i know he's got
big pouty lips i know he looks like he's
going to cry every time they call a
penalty on him but the stats don't lie
the stats don't lie
the guy's a [ __ ] phenomenal player
the last time
you know playing for the gold it went
into overtime when all of canada had
their frozen balls up it pulled up into
their bodies
after we scored the [ __ ] game tire
tire at the end of regulation remember
that
who came out and scored the [ __ ] goal
crosby the guy delivers all right so
[ __ ] all you flyer fans and all you
other [ __ ] who can't give it up to him
i don't like him
just for the simple fact that he plays
for the penguins but i'd love to have
him on my team there you go
all right so anyways
this is the monday morning podcast if
you're new to it welcome
um i do one of these every single week i
tape on monday mornings unless my
throat's hurting me
in that case i tape them a little later
but it is my podcast so i do it when i
want to and when i you know when they're
allegedly late
you know which i don't understand like
how am i late to my own
business i got the keys i'm opening up
[Music]
all right here we go
i'm going to tell you guys a story or
that adds another layer
to how dumb i am
right after i do a little bit of
advertising oh [ __ ] you [ __ ] you i gotta
make money too here we go hulu plus
everybody
hulu plus everyone hey
you've probably tried hulu.com
hanging out with your friends now with
hulu plus you can watch your favorite
shows anytime any where
hulu plus lets you watch thousands of
hit tv shows and a selection of
acclaimed movies on your television or
on the go with your smartphone or tablet
and it all streams in hd for the best
viewing experience with hulu plus you
can watch your favorite current tv shows
like saturday night live community and
family guy you can also check out
exclusive content including hulu
originals like the awesomes starring snl
seth myers who by the way tonight watch
him his debut taking over late night
the
fourth host
of late night
started off with the king dave letterman
went to conan o'brien went to jimmy
fallon
now to seth meyers sorry back to the
advertisement and moon boy starring
chris o'dowd from bridesmaids hulu plus
also offers a great selection of
acclaimed films for only 7.99 a month
you can get all of this you can stream
as many tv shows and movies as you want
wherever you want right now you can try
hulu plus for free for two freaking
weeks when you go to huluplus.com
that's a special offer for my listeners
i'm pointing at myself with my thumb
make sure you use
huluplus.com so you get an extended free
trial and they know that i sent you
huluplus.com bill now or click the hulu
plus banner on the podcast page
um at billberg.com there you go
you like it
all right
okay guys you've heard me talk about how
much i love love
dollarshaveclub.com so why haven't you
joined
why haven't you joined what's stopping
you do you have a fear of success like
you
uh like you don't have anything better
to do other than go to the store
or anything better to spend your money
on than uh overpriced razors dollar
shave club what's wrong with you people
what's wrong with you people
come on guys this is this is one of this
is a layup
all right in the last two years
dollarshaveclub.com has saved hundreds
of thousands of dollars of guy of guys
times by delivering amazing quality
razors
uh high quality grooming products right
to your door all right you've been
getting screwed for years
overpaying for your razor blades you
don't have to anymore go to
dollarshaveclub.com forward slash burr
shave with their razors
um i am a forex guy evidently but my
buddy swears by his executive who am i
talking about i don't know why can't i
wasn't it enough that i love this
product you gotta invent friends for me
anyways and also check out my favorite
doctor covey's easy shave butter
whoa
seriously this stuff is amazing it makes
shaving feel like you you're softly
whipping whiskers off of your face
and you can't forget about one wipe
charlies the butt wipes for men that's
right a butt white for men peppermint
tingle enough said
what are you waiting for you can get
deliveries every other month if you need
and you can cancel any time if you don't
like it um this this whole deal is
airtight
dollarshaveclub.com wants you to i don't
need to read the rest of it it's great
this is what you need save time shave
money join dollarshaveclub.com go to
dollarshaveclub.com
let them know i sent you that's
dollarshaveclub.com forward slash burr
or go to billboard.com and click on the
dollar shave club banner all right
if you don't do this then you just like
misery okay
all right so here's the story of me
being an absolute [ __ ] [ __ ]
all right um i had a wonderful
run of shows last week tuesday through
last night sunday night at the new
jersey pack center in newark new jersey
um
my week started off with my favorite
show of the year now uh the second
annual patrice o'neill comedy benefit um
amazing three-hour show
with um there wasn't anybody on that
show that i that i wasn't a huge fan of
the crowd was unbelievable
i want to thank all of the comics
who uh donated their time
um
it was just an amazing amazing night and
i want to thank opie and anthony and jim
norton for hyping the show moving all
those tickets it was a huge success
and uh for those of you who came and all
that just know that um patrice's mom and
his uh
his uh his wife and stepdaughter were
over the moon happy so you guys really
did a great thing by buying tickets to
that show it's a wonderful thing we're
definitely gonna do it again next year
we're gonna try to expand it
um in many different ways for next year
but uh it was a huge success and i could
have done it without maureen taran
behind the scenes and uh all the comics
and opium anthony and all the fans that
came out so from the bottom of my heart
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you all right so that was the
tuesday night
um
and it was a great night too we had the
after party everybody was hanging out
and uh versus hilarious he shows up like
around 11 30 right i'm like hey what's
up whatever he's pacing back and forth
like a friggin caged
goddamn cat i don't know what the [ __ ]
going on with them right finally i look
up and make eye contact with him and he
is walking by me just eyeballing me
right out the side of his head with this
[ __ ]
not quite a grin not quite a scowl but
he is looking at me
and i'm like jesus christ all right
you know
what what what is this here all my
stupid phone's going off here
i'm like what is the problem
right so i get up and i walk over and
he's like hey he's like dude you want to
smoke stoke
i got first dog i'm like absolutely so
he goes i got a place i got a place so
long story short the whole thing dies
down around one o'clock in the morning
and we leave there
takes me to this insane [ __ ] cigar
bar
and we go in there they got all these
different kinds of cigars so we just
[ __ ] do it up
we got like this nicaraguan cigar with
like aged 10 years tobacco dude i swear
to god i lit this [ __ ] thing
i almost puked
thank god
i wasn't drinking
because this thing was like huffing on
the tailpipe of my [ __ ] f-100 man i
swear to god
but once you got the thing lit
once i got it lit um
it would it was a whole other
it was just a whole other deal
um
it was amazing
it was like smoking a blunt you got like
high off this [ __ ] thing this is
going to kill a lot of purists i'm still
not drinking i'm a month in 28 days four
weeks
um
i actually gotta know duels with it
i know i i'm waiting for every guy out
ah jesus christ what are you a [ __ ]
queer there yes
i [ __ ] i had drank at all duels i
have to all right
i got a 20-day door tour canada coming
up damage will be done i'm in basic
training right now
all right
[ __ ] what are those old army marches
what do they say i don't they always say
you're gay
or you're part cattle don't they do that
are they allowed to do any of those
anymore
you know now that they have um openly
gay people in the military i guess like
half of their jokes were out the window
where are you from
all things from there stairs and choirs
you ain't got no horns right but they're
hacky [ __ ] jokes they had to update
it only thing from there is steers and
homosexuals
[ __ ] it doesn't rhyme
goddammit give me 20.
um
anyways
completely lost my train of thoughts so
we we smoked these cigars i'm drinking
of [ __ ] oduals
and it was still great that's how
unbelievable this cigar was and it was
so strong like i don't need
this is me lying to myself saying i
don't need another cigar i'm not gonna
lie i want to [ __ ] smoke one tonight
but i'm not gonna
i always let you know
i get scratched up a little bit
by alcohol and cigars but i never let it
get its hooks in me
you know
and that's because of my uh
i have that german irish stubborn thing
where i can push through [ __ ]
because
if i didn't and i know a lot of people
irish a bunch of [ __ ] alcoholics you
know what a lot of us aren't okay and it
would be nice if you brought us up every
once in a while
i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm saying i
just basically how i'm wired i feel when
something's getting its hooks in me
and
i continue to abuse it for like another
three months and then i go all right i
got to stop
um
so that's what i do with cigars
although now just by talking about them
now i'm i'm [ __ ]
hear that that's me [ __ ] hit in the
bed right now i want one
which is why i'm not gonna smoke one
i keep it at bay you know what i mean
like that guy who doesn't want to be in
a relationship you know he bangs her
every two weeks and then doesn't call
her since she doesn't develop feelings
and he shows up again hey look who's
here oh is that my dick hey right and
then you're [ __ ] leaving it
[Music]
so anyways
the next night
i'm out at westbury theater the second
time i performed there that's that one
that holly mandel did a special there i
believe brian regan did a special there
it's [ __ ] amazing
in the round i went out there i
oh wait a minute wait a minute the night
of patrice's thing we [ __ ] went over
there and the cigar bar was closed
so when we went out to westbury that's
what we did after westbury we went in
there um we we had [ __ ] great show
paul verzi
arguably the best set i've ever seen him
beyond being funny
son of a [ __ ] is smooth as hell now i'm
talking a little [ __ ] for you there
versie [ __ ] guy is smooth as hell
looks like a total pro
handling being in the round
no problem whatsoever um [ __ ] killing
it
and got that applause beyond
thank god you know you're done bring on
the next guy he got he got a sustained
appreciation and a round of applause
um
which was great for me to see as a
friend and then it also sucks as a
friend because i know he's gonna be
headlining his own [ __ ] soon and then he
won't be opening for me anymore which
sucks
i mean it's great for my liver
you know and the mouth cancer there um
anyways um
yes then we went to the cigar bar and
all that [ __ ] happens and then the
next night
i drove all the way down now i'm working
with this dude nate craig
uh
we [ __ ] drive all the way down to uh
charlottesville virginia
supposed to be a six-hour drive turned
into a [ __ ] nine-hour drive
because they're digging up all the
goddamn roads
you know
but it was interesting man we were going
through like these high i always just
take 95 down we actually got off at 95
and kind of angled over there and all of
a sudden we're just going by these open
fields that have like these cannons in
them i'm like what the [ __ ] are the
cannons sitting there
someone's going to steal that thing then
we real oh there's a civil war
battlefields
[ __ ] insane they're not even that big
kind of like the orange bowl do you ever
remember the orange bowl how small it
was when you finally went and saw it if
you'd seen some of the new stadiums how
[ __ ] gigantic they are like lucas
oilfield
like the battlefields they're really
small
at least the ones that i drove by at 40
miles an hour without really
looking at too much appeared to be
um
anyways did a show in fredericksburg no
i'm sorry
what did i say charlottesville next day
drove up to fredericksburg i think it
was at frederick's hill i don't know
what the [ __ ] it was someplace in
maryland then went that back down to
richmond
and then
had brutal traffic all the way up to the
new jersey uh
newark gig but all the shows were
awesome and um
all right so the knight ends
had a great run nate was killing it the
whole time i hadn't worked with him in
like a year and i saw all his progress
that he's made as a comic and i'm
telling you man that like
inspires me to have a better show
that's the kind of people i like working
with i like working with people that are
growing you know
these [ __ ] people you come and you
see him like a year or two later and
like their act hasn't changed at all
it's like depressing
to see that it's like going back to the
towny bar and there's that guy
[ __ ] guy that was sitting there the
last time you were there still wearing
the football jacket and [ __ ] they're
just stuck in the mud
drives me nuts so whatever anyways
um i'm now noticing my levels low
i'm not gonna [ __ ] with this this is
where it was last week and nobody
bitched
all i'm getting is one green light hello
test [ __ ] you all right that's good
anyways um
so uh so this morning
i go to leave in the rental car nate's
been driving the rental car the whole
[ __ ] time i get down there i've
already packed
um i already have it mapped out how to
get to newark airport from where i'm at
because it's really tricky from downtown
secure this [ __ ] route i have
everything ready to go
i wake up 6 20 i'm down at the rental
car by like 6 30 6 35 i get in it
everything's good i got my little card
to get out of the [ __ ] garage
finally i'm organized
and then i'm looking at the keys
and all i see is just a square
like in my prius where you just take the
square like magic key that you can
unlock it from 50 paces and you just
stick it in the key badge that they now
have in the dashboard
and i'm looking around and there isn't
one all i see is a place where you stick
the key in
and i'm looking going you got to be
[ __ ] me i'm digging in my pockets i
can't find the [ __ ] key
it's 6 35 in the morning nate is sound
asleep he's the last one who drove and
i'm going you got to be [ __ ] kidding
me
you got to be kidding me i look down at
the key chain there's another little key
ring
and i can see like it's all separated
like a key could have just fell off and
i'm like you got to be [ __ ] kidding
me
i'm just like really i start doing that
really
really god really what the [ __ ] did i do
to deserve this one i can't just have a
[ __ ] quick trip to the goddamn
airport so now i'm literally i'm already
going okay i'm calling nate if he
doesn't pick up i am abandoning this
[ __ ] vehicle [ __ ] this i'm getting in
a goddamn cab i'm walking up i'm taking
the magic key portion of this thing and
going it's your own [ __ ] fault for
sticking a a magic you know the magic
key with the [ __ ] other key with the
with with the with the defective ring on
it
this ain't on me i'll tell you where
it's at you want to charge me 200 bucks
i don't give a [ __ ] i'm not missing my
flight going home to see my family all
right [ __ ] you i'm out
i'm already thinking that so nate picks
up like oh hello
right
i'm like dude i'm sorry to wake you up
but do you have the key i can't find the
key
so he starts walking around his room
rummaging through pockets and [ __ ]
and then he finally dawns on him he goes
wait he goes
he goes the keys on the thing
you just got to press the button
i go what are you talking about he goes
on the little
whatever the [ __ ] you call that thing
the thing that opens it and get puts on
the line because you just press the
button so i press the button and the key
comes out like a [ __ ] jackknife
and he heard it come out and he just
starts laughing at me
and there wasn't anything i could do i
just started laughing too and
i want to tell you guys that i am
embarrassed by this story but i'm not
like
that kind of [ __ ] happens like with any
remote
base level technology
i just can't figure it out i've used
keys like that in the past i haven't in
a while
but i i just it doesn't take a lot
to stump me like anything that has to do
with computers oh so and so just tweeted
at you you should go look it up i look
it up i can't find it
i i just i suck at it
[ __ ] suck at it
and i landed after i landed he called me
up and he was still saying dude like i
couldn't go back to sleep i was just
laying in the bed laughing at you
and i was going dude and i told him the
whole thing i said dude if you didn't
get on the phone i wasn't going back up
there i was literally going to abandon
the rental car
and he goes who the [ __ ] abandons
a rental car and i go [ __ ] successful
people do
you know keep your eye on the prize trim
the fat
you know
it's like the horse is stumbling just
[ __ ] shoot it now we're walking [ __ ]
it i'll call a cab i could never shoot a
horse for all you animal lovers out
there i just would call a cab and i was
prepared if he didn't pick up what i was
gonna do my backup plan was i was taking
my [ __ ] out of the back of it
i was locking it and i was going to
curse all the way to the lobby get a cab
and i was going to go back over to the
rental car place
walk right in there and go here here's
the keys here's where it's at i got only
have the magic part of it i don't know
where the [ __ ] another thing is
all right charge me whatever and the
person would have looked at me and would
have hit that button and that thing
would have opened up
and i would have just sat there looking
like i just would have laughed
i would just be like hey i'm a [ __ ]
idiot you know what do you want from me
that's what i you you didn't do enough
of a background check
[Laughter]
i don't know um
i'm really having like major self-esteem
problems because i already knew
all of this [ __ ] about me and then my
wife hit me with that you have add and i
told you last week when i was sitting
there getting ready to do the patrice
thing it's always like a very melancholy
thing to do
you know when someone you love like that
has died but you're doing something
positive there's still always that void
so i was talking to her about it and i
was literally getting emotional for
people who didn't listen last week i was
getting emotional about it and i looked
up and there was a spider on the ceiling
and i was like oh a spider and i just
started talking about spiders for like i
don't know i don't even know how long i
was gone and i brought my head back down
and she was just looking at me smiling
and i was it was just like i mean i
couldn't argue with her at that point so
you know i i don't know what's you know
it really explains now
why i did so horribly in school
i just remember being in these classes
and it was just me and a bunch of other
fuck-ups
and i would be sitting in the class just
going i know i'm not as dumb as the
grade that i'm getting in this like i
can't be
because if i if i was
i wouldn't be aware of how how much of a
failure i am
would i
like you think really dumb people are
aware of it
you know that look on their faces they
try to figure [ __ ] out but then again
then i can go around and i can like
a little heidi key thing can confuse the
[ __ ] out of me
[ __ ] nate was hilarious he goes
what's your address i'm going to send
your wife some flowers
[Music]
just for having to live with me
do you realize how [ __ ] sad that is
of course you do and i know you're
enjoying every bit of this but anyways i
went um
i went back to the uh the hotel
because i was being a good boy the uh
this whole week not drinking
um
and i actually saw
i saw a couple of [ __ ] just great old
i kiss me deadly i always come on when
it's in the middle what a [ __ ] great
movie that is
i know a lot of people from my
generation and after know that as a
leader ford song it's actually a film
noir movie
and the lead of the movie who i should
really look up because uh
i like what this guy did like
he crushed it in that movie and a lot of
people say
it's a uh
it's a prototype
for all the uh all the tough guy movies
this role of the guy out ralph meeker
i'll actually look this guy up and he he
came around during like the studio
system
for all you uh football fans and and
sports fans out there
the studio system back then was kind of
like back
um like sports before they had like free
agency
well like back in the day
say if you if you played center field
for the yankees
okay and
during the detail end of joe dimaggio's
career
and the beginning of mickey mantle's
career you were [ __ ]
you were never getting brought up and
they weren't going to release you and
you didn't make it to the majors simply
because
two of the greatest center fielders of
all time happened to be playing for the
team that drafted you and you were
[ __ ] you couldn't go anywhere i don't
i guess maybe you try to switch
positions i don't know what you did back
in the day studio system they basically
they groomed you they brought you up
they changed your name like they did
with marilyn monroe and you just did
movies for them so anyways they wanted
this guy uh
let me look him up here so i gotta get
the story right ralph meeker they wanted
him
to uh to sign one of those contracts
and uh he refused to so he got like
blackballed
and it kind of [ __ ] up his career
um but i totally respect
that you know he did something like that
man i
i don't like getting tied down like that
either it's just like i'm not [ __ ]
i didn't get in this business to work
for you i'll do a job with you
you're gonna own me forever go [ __ ]
yourself but um
it's it's just a great movie
he just slaps a bunch of people around a
bunch of people get shot
there's some bad acting in it too
because it's
1955 or whatever you know
um that one came on
um
which has just a [ __ ] it just
really crazy ending the first time i saw
it
disturbed me disturbing ending but i'm
gonna let you guys know i'm not one of
those movie snobs like i got when i saw
blair witch by myself i got scared it
freaked me out i saw the ring i get
scared like i take the ride with the
movie i don't sit there going fake
that was lame
unless it really sucks so take it with a
grain of salt all right
um i saw that and then i also saw uh
i watched an episode of the honeymooners
and i realized
that i am i have a lot of ralph crammed
him in me
i just watched that guy he gets worked
up over little things he catastrophizes
he flips out he screams at the woman in
his life
and then in the end he realized not only
is he in the wrong he's a hundred
percent wrong and then he goes and he
apologizes
to his wife and then for some reason she
accepts the apology and that that's
basically my life
so i learned that and then i also
learned this superstition that i have
like i don't put a hat on the bed
and i never
i never uh
i never even heard of that
the hat on the bed thing being bad luck
until uh billy bob thornton was talking
about it like all his superstitions and
how he doesn't like antique furniture
which is hilarious he's just like it
creeps me out
[Music]
and i gotta tell you i've gone into some
antique [ __ ] places and the smell in
there it's the smell of death and i
totally understood it but for some
reason i never researched the hat on the
bed why it was considered bad luck but
if i threw a baseball hat down on the
bed i'd immediately knock it off i
actually believed in it
and
um so i actually was looking up these
things while nate was driving the
origins of all this
and the the hat on the bed
was basically hair was back in the day
was thought to i guess hold evil
spirits because a lot of people wore
hats back then and you took your hat off
in the static electricity sometimes
they'd see a little flash of light in
there and i guess they had no idea what
what it was like there's lightning in
your hair
i mean i don't know if they were still
drawn on cave walls at that point but
they had enough technology to make a
[ __ ] hat so i don't know where it
came from but anyways they thought the
evil spirits
were uh in your hair and you know they
they were
they got into your hat
and if you put the hat on the bed it
would get into the sheets and into the
mattress which makes no [ __ ] sense
because if it's already in your hair
then it's in your pillow why doesn't it
drip down into your [ __ ] brain
none of it makes any sense so now i'm
over it so now i went out of my way to
put a [ __ ] hat on the bed
right nothing bad's happening
a bunch of good shit's happening for me
i can focus on the bad stuff i couldn't
figure out the magic key this morning
right
i couldn't figure that out well well
bad [ __ ] happens
you know what i'm going to read this
thing that i that i read to [ __ ] nate
and it is that's his nickname [ __ ]
nate
um
was it origins
of
bad luck here we go let's see if i can
get the top ten
that's the number 13.
what is it how about how about this how
about the hang in there guys
top 10 bad luck
superstitions here we go maybe this is
it right here
oh where the [ __ ] 25 most popular
superstitions there were some really
good ones in there like the ladder
walking under a ladder the ladder when
it's leaned up against the wall forms a
triangle which is like the trinity or
something and you're supposed to be like
insulting god if you do that
um
in some parts of turkey you may want to
think twice before whipping out the
chewing gum there's a belief that if you
are chewing gum at night it is actually
rotting dead flesh
well i think that's a little has a
little more to say about the uh
turkey's food and drug administration
than it does above
growning cheese for a newborn
is this from the northern hemisphere
what the [ __ ] is this
you've probably heard of swiss cheese
cheddar cheese or pepper jack cheese but
have you heard of growing cheese
no i haven't
you've probably heard of get to the
[ __ ] point start trying to fill out
your paragraph in medieval england
expectant mothers made what they called
a groaning cheese which was a large
wheel of cheese that matured for nine
months as the unborn baby grew this is
already [ __ ] creepy
when the groaning time or the time of
the birth came how tough were broads
back then
the groaning time giving birth
without any [ __ ]
morphine
groaning that's all they did was groan
the [ __ ] husband's laying down
they're getting his entrails taken out
freedom
all right different kind of tough back
then
um when the groaning time came or the
time of the birth the whole family would
celebrate by eating this cheese
until nothing but the outer rind was
left
jesus christ were they all bound up or
what
then the guy's groaning trying to [ __ ]
the next day right the newborn would
then be passed through the rind on
christmas day to be blessed
with a long and prosperous life
what a cheesy superstition that says
well that's not bad luck is it
they had to sit there and eat all of
that to do that that whole [ __ ] thing
is gross
that's just [ __ ] gross i'm thinking a
bunch of gross [ __ ] with that
all right let's read one more here
friday the 13th has been the source of
the superstitions ever since the 19th
century though its origin is shrouded in
speculation and theories it's not going
to stop us from having a [ __ ] website
about it
sorry its impact is quite evident
many people will avoid well then you
don't even know what it is and you bring
it up you [ __ ]
all right [ __ ] this [ __ ] this website
okay you know what let's let's uh
do i have anything else i want to read
about oh by the way i found a new
documentary i haven't watched it yet
uh of course i don't know the name of it
they just unearthed it uh
who's the guy who got in the hot tub and
banged the 13 year old and then left the
country
what the [ __ ] his name rupert murdoch
billy ray valentine what the [ __ ] is his
name
ah [ __ ] i got it i have it it's a french
name
roman polanski
that was close rupert murdoch roman
polanski robert polanski he's got he
made a documentary on on jackie stewart
um roman
polanski
jackie
stewart documentary they just put it up
on netflix
it's from uh
it's from the early 70s i can't wait to
watch it formula one champion
weekend of champions
i guess it's up on uh
according to uh this car magazine i
bought on the plane i guess it's up on
netflix weekend of champions i'm gonna
watch it you should watch it you should
watch true detective
you should keep watching fast and loud
these are the shows that i like these
are the shows i recommend all right
let's get back to the uh the podcast
here um
where are we
oh jesus the whole thing's off the
[ __ ]
it's just gone off the god damn rails
here um i think i talked about
everything
there's a gay
basketball player now i this is going to
be the greatest [ __ ] thing ever if
these the gay football player and the
gay basketball player might make a bunch
of
sports players
players of professional sports come out
it's going to be the funniest [ __ ]
[ __ ] i cannot [ __ ] wait
nobody has stepped in [ __ ] yet either
all right um not i didn't mean it like
that
all right nobody has [ __ ] up
everybody is trained everybody knows
what to say
i think part of it is people are
educated now but also people have seen
enough other people get in trouble
most recently the duck hunter guy
so everybody's just saying the right
thing hey can the guy play the guy can
play can be on jake i don't think it's
any big deal 2014. they're all saying
that [ __ ] but i guarantee you somebody's
gonna [ __ ] up
who's it gonna be
who's your money on
what sport who do you like
trying to think somebody
you know if this was a big election year
some dark horse republican
ultra ultra conservative in his 60s he
would definitely say something
you know i don't think they should be on
the field
i think they should be cured first
before they're allowed in the locker
room they'd say something like that but
i'm telling you it's going to open the
floodgates
and uh
right now what's funny is espn is just
talking about it and talking about it
just praying that somebody's gonna [ __ ]
up and cause the controversy but nobody
gives a [ __ ] in a good way they're like
who gives a [ __ ] can the guy play get
him on the goddamn team right like that
guy coming out of missouri he's the sec
defensive player of the year i want him
on my team
all right but espn they can't keep the
air underneath it any [ __ ] longer
they're running
it's just they're running out of [ __ ]
it's hilarious it's just everybody being
100
accepting they need somebody to [ __ ] up
so for the love of god if you're a [ __ ]
if you're a bible beater if you're down
there in the jesus jet stream i know
they're they're going to stick a
microphone in somebody's face they can't
get a coach they can't get a player they
can't get an owner to [ __ ] up i
guarantee you their next [ __ ] move
because they're that the story is dying
they're gonna have to just start walking
around talking to people on the street
and just just basically entrapping
people
that's my prediction i'm calling that
for this week all right
they're gonna snuff it out
all right like the marines on iwo jima
walking up that [ __ ] mountain
snuffing them up
um because they're not on the island
they're in it i told you i'm reading
that book flags of your fathers
flags of our fathers or whatever
unbelievable
unfucking believable another
unbelievable book and i they think of
the [ __ ] that sets me off the [ __ ] that
these guys went through
you know they made that saving private
ryan and you think that like that sort
of landing was
a uh it was an exception rather than the
norm all throughout from what i'm
reading
as these marines were taken
island by island out in the pacific it
was d-day every [ __ ] day and iwo jima
was the worst
this [ __ ]
japanese general he he he let him all
gather on the beach he didn't just start
shooting at him
you know then the navy had bombarded the
island for like they were supposed to do
it for like five six days they only did
it like two or three days
and they didn't realize that
the japanese they were in it
they had like 16 miles of tunnels they
had these pill boxes
you know
basically just wide enough to stick
their guns through
and they let all the marines gather on
the beach before they opened up on them
just i i don't even like some of the
horrible [ __ ] that they were talking
about i don't even know how you they
were saying it was so shocking some
people just
one of the things when you when you're
dealing with that something that
overwhelming is your body you actually
just go to into a deep sleep
like you fall asleep like you're laying
on the couch
during the four o'clock game
you know what i mean and like sergeants
would be kicking guys trying to wake him
up
and you would come too like [ __ ]
you probably were pissed like why didn't
you let me just keep sleeping
um
unbelievable book highly recommend it
obviously they made it into a movie and
all that [ __ ] i think they did i know
it's a huge book but uh
you know i figure if you guys listen to
me read every week out loud that you
guys aren't big readers too so i still
also need to recommend highly uh
successful books there all right why
don't i shut the [ __ ] up
and uh
i'll do a little more advertising i'll
leave the last couple of ads here and
then we'll go into the questions for
this week sound good beautiful all right
stamps.com you've probably heard the
cost of a stamp just went up to 49
49 cents jesus christ but not if you
have stamps.com with stamps.com you'll
pay less for postage than you would at
the post office for first class mail
priority and priority mail express
packages and more stamps.com is easy to
use and convenient buy and print
discounted stamps shipping labels and
more using your own computer and your
printer not only will you save money
with stamps.com by not paying full price
for postage you'll save valuable time
too stance.com always keeps the rates up
to date so you'll always have the exact
postage you need every time right from
your desk never repeat never go to the
post office again i use stamps.com to
send out all my posters and dvds i'm a
[ __ ] i can figure it out so can you
right now use my last name bur b-u-r-r
for the b-u-r-r for the special offer no
risk trial plus 110 bonus offer that
includes a digital scale and up to 55
dollars free postage don't wait go to
stamps.com before you do anything else
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page and type in bur that
stamps dot com enter bur
and lastly but not leastly
uh e-voice
you're a business owner but automated
phone systems and secretaries are not in
your budget just yet and juggling
incoming calls yourself makes it really
hard to look like a professional there
here's something that will dramatically
help you make more money in 2014 e-voice
whether you're a business of one or one
hundred e-voice will help you manage all
of your incoming calls with a toll-free
number
dial by name directory and call routing
tools your business will sound like a
million bucks can't take a call no
problem e-voice will transcribe the
voicemail and email it to you never be
caught off guard again and with e-voice
you can try it before you buy it right
now just for my listeners you can get a
60-day trial to e-voice for absolutely
free go to e-voice.com and enter the
promo code bill
b-i-l-l at the uh at the checkout take
charge of your business and make more
money in 2014 go to evoice.com and enter
bill at checkout for your 60 day free
trial two months for free that's evoice
dot com promo code bill
all right there you go
my painful reading out loud is over for
this week at least the advertising is
now for the questions
all right response to plantar
fischeritis
that's the pain in the bottom of my foot
that is on again off again sir billiam i
have
this yeah yes plantar
always say uh a couple years ago i had
it a couple years ago and my doctor told
me two things one there are straps that
you can put onto your feet to stretch
them out as you're sleeping and they
wrap around your feet to your calf
i don't like that [ __ ] number two
uh number two worked for me and that was
to sleep with
my feet hanging off the bed
oh number two okay that's the second
option so either you do the straps you
have your feet hanging off the bed this
makes sure that they won't curl up
on you while you're sleeping
after about two to three weeks my feet
started to feel better well my feet feel
fine it's just like if i don't stretch
ridiculously before i play drums
or run a little bit
skip rope or anything like that like if
the pain comes back
uh i want to know how to rehab it how do
i strengthen it up so i can actually run
again
um but i do appreciate what you're
telling me there
um there's somebody else number two uh
dear billy blue balls i heard you were
struggling with the plantar fasciitis
and since my girlfriend is a doctor of
physical therapy i summoned her
expertise to help eliminate some of your
pain she said
she hundred percent agrees with your
morning stretching routine she also
commented that there are a couple more
things that could potentially help such
as golf ball in the freezer
pulling it out a couple times a day to
roll on your footsies as well uh filling
a dixie cup with water and freezing it
once frozen you can peel away the dixie
cup as desired
to provide a manageable smooth block of
ice you may find somewhere neat some
relief by using a technique called ice
massaging massaging under the arch of
your foot she also mentioned possibly
orthotic options and my favorite begging
the lovely nia to deeply massage the
affected area to help break up the
adhesion from overworked tendon i i'm at
that point
what i need people i need how do i rehab
it how do i strengthen it up
um
because i'm already doing most of that
i do the tennis ball thing like when i
go to play drums in my little drum bag i
actually have a tennis ball
and i got a whole routine i roll in and
it doesn't bug me but my thing is if i
don't do that every [ __ ] time if i
just sit down to play like the the it's
annoyed again
now is that for life because once you
get it you get it or can i actually
build it back up again
like
if i don't stretch i always feel like
it's right i feel like i'm a week after
the injury happened do you know what i
mean i don't go back with the affliction
but it's a nagging pain
so ask your wife or girlfriend there is
uh
am i [ __ ] for life with this or can i
actually build it back up again the way
you know i've torn muscles and i'm able
to build it back up every once in a
while something will happen
ah gives a [ __ ] i don't know all right
bill why the back and forth
uh billy dee williams why do you start
and quit drinking so much you're truly
not an alcoholic well you can say that
from what listening to the podcast he
goes of course i can't know for this
this for sure okay he just put himself
back in check i apologize
uh but this doesn't but it doesn't seem
like you need booze to get through the
day you're not a different person when
you drink it's not like holy [ __ ] bill's
drinking again hide your punch lines and
put the kids to bed you literally you're
literally the oprah of boo's consumption
relax
with this whole wagon [ __ ] wagons
are like wheelchairs don't [ __ ] with it
unless you need it have a whiskey you'll
be fine tell versi i think he's
a two-beer queer i called it uh no dude
you need to hang out with us
you have to understand that
how would you drink okay if at the end
of every day there was an open bar
free by the way i guess open bar is free
i'm an idiot
an open bar free bar pie a la mode with
ice cream please
um
yeah that's the thing like i have an
unbelievable amount of free time and i
drink as much as two of my friends
who've gone to uh the doctor and found
out that they had an enlarged liver
so and then also
it ages you you get a puffy face and all
that so what i do is yeah
a little binge and purge little binge
and purge
i'm doing great i'm still in great shape
i still look good
you know
i'm losing the roof but everything else
is looking all right you know what do
you want from me i appreciate your
concern
but um you know
i just went on basically like a two-year
bender i took a year off and then i came
back came back strong
picked up right where i left off
dude i had four [ __ ] white russians
who does that
before i got on a plane
woke up with a splitting headache and i
felt like ate a bag of halloween candy
who does that
you know [ __ ] idiot i need to take a
little time out i feel great after 28
days it's good to give you your liver a
break every once in a while
um
but believe me i'm going to up to canada
in the same way a woman
goes to the bahamas or goes to the
tropics
and [ __ ] around on her husband and says
it doesn't count because i'm outside of
the country i do the same thing with
booze
it doesn't count i'm in canada
what am i supposed to do it's [ __ ]
cold up here all right gay guy who likes
a girl
a billion dollar bill i'm a 20 year old
gay guy and i rece and recently i've
started to like my best friend who is a
girl i never liked a girl before so this
is uncharted territory for me she knows
i'm gay we go to the movies alone
together and have and have sleepovers
and really just do things that i know
she wouldn't do with her guy friends who
weren't gay
okay um
so you get to [ __ ] sleep in the same
sleeping bag with her she knows that
you're not gonna be poking her is that
what it is
anyways her boyfriend who i don't know
too well is cool with us
spending so much time together because
he knows i'm gay and therefore am no
threat to him about a month ago i was
spending the night in a room when she
took her shirt off and started changing
in front of me she's comfortable she's
comfortable enough with me that she's
changed in the same room i was in before
and i never really cared because she
always had a bra on underneath
this time she didn't
so i saw her tits
you sound like a straight guy that you
said tits it's really blunt so i saw her
tits
instead of her breastuses i saw her tits
and it was the first time i've ever seen
a girl naked before
ever since that happened i've had a huge
crush on her
more than i've ever
liked a guy even so wait a minute
so that means what you saw a naked guy
first and then you just went with guys
and now that you've seen a woman
this is dude this is beyond me this is
really [ __ ] interesting
so you have a serious like crush
he goes i think about her all the time
often sexually and now i feel dishonest
every time i see her because she still
thinks i'm gay while in reality i'm
sometimes there thinking about what it'd
be like to [ __ ] her
hey buddy welcome aboard
permission granted come on aboard i'm
loving this story telling her i like her
would get me nowhere since she has a
boyfriend but i hate living with the
guilt of her not knowing what should i
do i'll tell you what you do shut the
[ __ ] up is what you do
that is that is a a a
that is a [ __ ] [ __ ] storm private
you stand the [ __ ] down on that one all
right if you think this is what why
don't you go try out your new desires on
someone outside of that relationship
okay
um
i would definitely uh
i don't know what to tell you
i i i this is [ __ ] dude you gotta
call dr drew on this one i gotta i gotta
throw out a lifeline here i i would
go out to a bar
and uh you know what god damn it i need
a gay friend for this one
you know what
i'm gonna ask a gay friend and i'm gonna
get back to you next week what do you
think about that all right in the
meantime
don't [ __ ]
pull a facebook here and just [ __ ]
vomit all your feelings don't do that
okay i know i'm sounding like i'm being
a dick but i'm helping you out here this
is a [ __ ] storm here
because
first of all she's in a [ __ ]
relationship with somebody
you don't want to do that
um she's also now friends with you
and she thinks you're gay and she thinks
that she can trust you and if all of a
sudden you come [ __ ] walking at her
with a [ __ ] stinger
she's gonna think about all the times
she [ __ ]
changed in front of you
and it's just really gonna creep her out
uh
i don't know what to tell you dude
like
i would say right now stop sleeping over
there figure out what the [ __ ] going
on
but uh i need some i need some i need
some gay help i need some gulp on this
one
gay people any gay people out there
wherever you are come in come in come in
uh yeah help me out on this one
we'll have we'll have a new section on
the podcast gelp
gay help help me out on this one
i don't know what to tell this dude
all right
all right uh girl wanted to roofie me
jesus these are some interesting ones
this week
bill don't worry this isn't a this isn't
some creepy story oh it's one of those
mainstream roofie stories
um the person says i i got to college
in the northeast last weekend my buddies
and i had a party and i invited this
yeah you left out the word i'm going to
guess girl from one of my classes
because we were always laughing together
blah blah blah blah so she shows up and
she looks amazing ah what a great story
what a great time in your life what
could go wrong we started laughing doing
shots even better she starts leaning
into me more as the night goes on ah
memories
like the corners of my mind after things
start to settle and her dumb friends
leave
[Laughter]
we go up to my room
she sits on my bed and asks me if the
door is locked i tell her yes
capital y es with confidence and also
confusion
she then pulls something out of her bag
and asks if i want to get crazy with her
i say well
not the kind of fun that will result in
me gargling
my own chunks like hendrix
ah jesus
i hope you didn't say that uh she got
the joke and laughed all right she's a
keeper
uh i felt good about what was to come
maybe it was ecstasy i'd never done
ecstasy and that could be fun right
nope capital n-o-p-e she then says
this is a low-grade roofie
want to split it
dude this went from
a coming-of-age story to immediately one
of the most [ __ ] up
this is a whole new room
i've never been in this room
i'm going to stand near the door on the
for the rest of this uh now you might be
thinking this is mutual how can this go
wrong we'd both be on the same medicine
i was intrigued bill very intrigued i
sat down at my desk
and put on some music and stalled as i
thought about it then i heard
your voice in my head dude either banger
clean or get the [ __ ] out
uh i'm a good kid from a small town and
i'd rather jerk her for the rest of my
life than panita or dumb female good for
you if you don't want to do it don't
[ __ ] do it let alone partake in
something that nuts i still collect
baseball cards you know
if you can't do the math no dude i
listen
i still buy old football cards i'm right
there with you and there's a bunch of
people out there who could literally
just [ __ ] a goddamn ostrich on the
50-yard line in a football game it
wouldn't give a [ __ ] they would do it
and they would feel fine about it the
next day and they should do it
all right if you're more wired that way
yeah don't do it he goes so i told her
uh this can only go bad for me she then
says how about
only you take it
what
dude you need to get this girl the [ __ ]
out of the room before she takes out a
strap-on
um
i don't like this at all this is
creeping me up
she says i tell her
that
that is only a terrible idea she laughed
a little bit and then i explained the
situation to her dude wait a minute she
goes is the door locked
she pulls out a roofie let's split it
what if only you take it
dude this is uh this this isn't good
she goes i said
okay wait
she laughed a bit and then i explained
the situation to her i said look babe
you put me in a terrible position here
because i wanted to strip you down and
have at it but i can't with that thing
in the room it's a loaded gun i told her
i told her we were going to walk
together to the bathroom and flush it
neither one of us being alone with the
powerful supplement she laughed and said
she understood we started going at it
and the next morning she said i'm sorry
if that was weird i'm glad you're a
smart guy
that earned you a threesome with my
friend from home just say when oh my god
where the [ __ ] did that hollywood ending
come from
bill within 12 hours i went from here's
some good old-fashioned college fund to
preparing my defense to how can i
satisfy her and her friend properly
there's only one way to learn [ __ ] go
jump in it
i'm such a dumb guy after she pulls out
a roof he [ __ ] this she goes so how do
so how'd i do
would you ever eat a roofie with no [ __ ]
no
the answer is is always no right
absolute you you saying no [ __ ]
walked you into a threesome
jesus [ __ ] christ dude if you don't
do a follow-up [ __ ] email to that i
don't even care if this isn't true this
is the greatest screenplay i've ever
read
ah that's [ __ ] phenomenal
more power to you there but for the
grace of god
that's [ __ ] phenomenal
all right here's the thing
you go over there this is the thing you
want this to be a home game
if you can't because she's a little
[ __ ] weird if they insist you go over
her place you gotta [ __ ] do it go
over there all right
don't let them spray you with any sort
of mist if they do you got to jump
through the screen door you got to get
the [ __ ] out of there all right
um other than that
[ __ ]
take the beach my friend
oh that's great that made my [ __ ]
week
all right third cousin dear billy
bandito i live in denver and i'm
visiting my family back in nebraska
recently uh i was visiting sorry my mom
and dad are both from the same small
town and had larger families so i have a
lot of family back there
uh i was with a cousin uh oh oh please
don't go sexual here also from denver
and if you don't go sexual i just said
that and it grossed you out i apologize
also from denver at a bar in a nearby
large town
and we were throwing back a couple of
beers
there was a pretty young lady at the bar
who surprisingly enough found me quite
charming one thing led to another and i
ended up going back to her place dude
great [ __ ] emails this week the next
morning we were grabbing some coughing
and having some more detailed
conversation about ourselves and it
turns out we have the same great grandpa
and grandma
oh no
i.e our parents are cousins making us
third cousins
in your mind is that weird yes
yet is that it is weird
is it is that legal
i'm no fool and wrapped my tool
jesus christ dude do you have that on a
t-shirt i'm no fool be no don't be a
fool wrap your tool i'm no fool and wrap
my tool but do you know what the chances
are me and this girl
would have created a mutant had i
knocked her up
thanks and go [ __ ] yourself well i can
look that up for you sir
on the lovely internet and like most
people who do research on the internet i
will take the first thing that i read as
law
third this is going to be on my computer
now because of you third cousin sex
legal question mark
cousin marriage law in the united states
oh god there's a [ __ ] chat here with
different colors
laws regarding first cousin marriage in
the united states
first cousin marriage is legal in
california
what hawaii alaska
massachusetts vermont new york no
[ __ ] way
criminal offenses texas you know
sometimes when texas is right they're
[ __ ] they're right oklahoma both the
dakotas and nevada
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
let's get the third cousin here
this is just first cousins where the
[ __ ] is third cousins how is first cuz
there's no [ __ ] way you can marry
your first cousin that isn't right that
was wikipedia by the way
incest cousin marriage law regarding
incest dude i don't want to be on this
part of the internet
dude you got to look this up okay
whatever you got away with it hopefully
just stay away from her
all right
jesus christ
when you notice somebody has the same
smile as you
like you haven't noticed the kennedys
they all have that [ __ ] horsetooth
smile
you know that's when you gotta [ __ ]
pull the plug and get away from you
anyways i got [ __ ] to do people i know
this is a kind of a short one oh it's an
hour and ten minutes i appreciate you
being patient uh my voice was a little
[ __ ] up after uh i did a lot of a lot
of comedy this week
and i had to give it a break uh i had to
give my instrument
a break um
that is it that's a podcast for this
week uh my big canada tour is coming up
and i'm gonna be back on the sauce and
i'm gonna be smoking cigars and i'm
gonna be
telling jokes and skating on a pawn near
you
up there in uh oh
can i do
you won both [ __ ] gold medals
i'm sure you're happy eating a bunch of
[ __ ] donuts go [ __ ] yourself i'm out
of time all right i'm out of time uh
i'll sing the canada song next week
uh that's it that's the podcast i'll
talk to you next week please keep the
emails coming and i need help
i need gulp this week to help out that
person there like what and do are there
any more stories like that that's
actually does that mean that person's
bisexual
i have no [ __ ] idea all right that's
it i'll talk to you next week